The first glimpses we got of Frozen 2 didn't
tell us much, but this latest trailer finally
gives us a clearer picture of the sequel's
storyline, and we've scoured each and every
frame for possible clues about what to expect
in Frozen 2.
At the beginning of Frozen, we see the picturesque
kingdom of Arendelle, which sits at the edge
of the sea, nestled into a wall of towering
cliffs.
Set apart from the village is Arendelle Castle,
rimmed with stone walls and topped with pointed
green roofs.
However, by the end of the film, the castle
has been transformed, not by the premature
winter which Elsa brings about after losing
control of her powers, but by gleaming ice
crystals that beautifully adorn all the rooftops
and spires, making the castle appear frosty
white.
The opening shot of the Frozen 2 trailer establishes
that Arendelle Castle is still sporting its
new look, with the white-tipped castle sitting
next to a peaceful town surrounded by lush
green grass.
By showing us that Elsa is still glazing the
castle in beautiful layers of ice, we can
assume that not only is Elsa still reigning
as Queen, but that she's in full control of
her powers, and at peace with her people.
The Frozen 2 trailer opens with a flashback,
as King Agnarr tells a young Anna and Elsa
a story about an enchanted forest.
In the story, we see an image of a young golden-haired
boy in Arendelle colors arriving in the forest
between what appears to be two palace guards.
Then we see a young girl twirling through
the air, and it's hard not to see the similarity
between her and the dark-haired Iduna.
These two children were also shown in an earlier
trailer, where the boy was the one being tossed
and the girl was the one watching.
Is it possible that this is a glimpse of the
first meeting of Agnarr and Iduna, and that
Iduna is, in fact, from the enchanted forest?
That could explain where Elsa's magic came
from.
"Born with the powers or cursed?"
"Born, and they're getting stronger."
Both previous Frozen 2 teasers have shown
us a scene in which one of the sisters was
surrounded by hovering, icy diamonds.
Now we have another piece of the puzzle, with
the revelation that the diamonds that Elsa
creates seem to match the symbols on the Stonehenge-like
pillars that mark the entrance to the enchanted
forest.
The trailer makes it appear as though one
of the central questions of Frozen 2 will
be where Elsa's powers came from, and her
ability to create symbols she's presumably
never seen before may be a major clue.
All signs seem to point to some sort of significant
link between Elsa and the enchanted forest,
but we'll have to wait to find out whether
it's the source of her power, the homeland
of one of her parents, or connected to her
magic in some other way.
We never had much doubt that Anna, Elsa, Kristoff,
and Olaf would return for Frozen 2, but less
certain were the fates of all the endearing
side characters from the first film.
While it would have been easy enough for Disney
to sweep Frozen's minor characters aside to
make room for a new crop, we now know at least
a few familiar faces will be making an appearance
in Frozen 2.
In a shot that presumably takes place shortly
after the citizens of Arendelle have been
forced to flee the village, we see the trolls
Bulda, Cliff, and Pabbie, who cared for Kristoff
as a child, standing in front of the displaced
townspeople.
Behind them is Oaken, the good-natured owner
of Oaken's Trading Post and Sauna, who made
the most of his brief appearance in the first
film.
"Now back up while I deal with this crook
here."
"What did you call me?"
While it seems as though the trolls may still
have a significant role to play in Frozen
2, chances are that Oaken's appearance will
be more of a cameo.
Still, it's be nice to see him again, and
maybe this time we'll even get to meet his
family.
"Yoo-hoo, hi family!
"Yoo-hoo!"
When Elsa hears a mysterious voice calling
to her, she sets out on a quest to figure
out who it is.
Or at least, that's the impression of Frozen
2's plot that we get from the trailer, which
sees Anna immediately volunteering to accompany
her sister as she ventures north in search
of answers.
From the looks of it, Frozen 2 will be largely
Elsa's movie, similar to how Frozen was mostly
about Anna.
Elsa appears to be on her own for a number
of scenes in the trailer, including the one
where she approaches the wall of mist surrounding
the enchanted forest.
It's easy to miss, since in the very next
shot, Anna is by her side.
Elsa's fear of hurting others and her inclination
to isolate herself to her own detriment were
major themes of the first film, so it'll be
interesting to see if, in Frozen 2, Elsa's
tendency to push forward on her own is still
a fatal flaw, or if it has somehow evolved
into a strength.
At one point in the trailer, Pabbie tells
Elsa that if she wants answers, she has to
find the source of the voice.
As he tells her this, he uses his magic to
give her a vision showing three scenes.
The first is a brief glimpse at a bridge that
looks like one of the structures of Arendelle.
The next is of two groups of people coming
face to face.
Then there's a third image, a staff and a
sword striking together.
This vision could easily foreshadow events
that will occur later in the film, but it
could also hint at the past event Agnarr referred
to in his story that led to the enchanted
forest being sealed off.
Perhaps the reason it's so important for Elsa
to learn about her past is so that she can
prevent similar events from happening again
in the future.
When Elsa, Anna, Kristoff, and Olaf take off
in their carriage for their trek north, a
tall, pillar-shaped mountain can be seen in
the distance.
If you look closely, you can see Elsa's ice
castle is still there on the side, exactly
as it was when she constructed it during the
"Let It Go" sequence from Frozen.
Since Frozen 2 is said to take place three
years after the first film, it's probably
safe to assume that this means Elsa still
spends some time in her ice castle.
Although Elsa seems to have made a healthy
home life for herself in Arendelle, it would
make sense if, from time to time, she retreats
to her own northern fortress of solitude to
decompress, burn off some magic, and perhaps
do a bit of general maintenance and upkeep.
Once Elsa manages to take her party through
the mist surrounding the enchanted forest,
the Arendelle crew encounters a number of
new characters who have been living on the
inside.
These include Yelana, who leads the Northuldra
people.
It appears as though they'll have a significant
role to play in Frozen 2.
We also meet Lieutenant Matthias, who seems
to be wearing a version of an Arendelle guard's
uniform, although it's worth noting that the
design is slightly off from the one we see
in Frozen.
Either the royal guard uniform has been updated
in the past three years, or Matthias and his
men are wearing an older version of the uniform,
and have been in the forest for a long time.
Perhaps the character we're most excited about,
though, is the tiny salamander named Bruni
whom we see excitedly lapping up Elsa's magic
snowflakes.
Bruni was the most adorable part of the trailer,
and according to Olaf voice actor Josh Gad,
that's just the beginning.
Gad tweeted:
"Meet your new future obsession.
You have no idea."
So far in the Frozen-verse, whenever rocks
start shaking, it's nothing to worry about.
It's almost always the kindhearted, waist-high
trolls, the same gentle people who took in
Kristoff when he was just a young boy.
However, Frozen 2 looks to be introducing
a whole new breed of rock people in the form
of towering stone giants.
And from the looks of things, they're not
very friendly.
The trailer sees Anna and Olaf steering a
boat past a group of sleeping stone giants,
keeping quiet so as not to wake them.
Later, we see Anna, Kristoff, and Sven fleeing
for their lives as a giant pursues them, hurling
rocks, and then a number of giants rising
up over the treetops.
Although we're assuming that the stone giants
aren't the real villains here, they're certainly
a formidable opponent, and we're pretty excited
to see what sort of magic Elsa conjures against
them.
It's a blink-and-you'll-miss-it shot, but
at one point in the trailer, Kristoff rides
Sven into the forest and scoops up Anna, leaving
a person who appears to be Elsa behind on
her hands and knees.
Apparently, Kristoff won't hesitate to save
Anna, even if it means leaving her sister
behind.
It's not unexpected, especially if the rumors
from D23 are true and Kristoff plans to propose
to Anna in Frozen 2, but it does feel significant.
We know from Frozen that Anna and Elsa will
always do everything they can to save one
another, but what happens if Kristoff decides
that saving Elsa is too risky for Anna?
We hope that Frozen 2 doesn't come down to
Anna having to choose between her boyfriend
and her sister, but if it does, there won't
be any contest.
Sorry, Kris.
Sisters before misters.
In a film that is presumably all about learning
where its characters came from, it's fitting
that we could get a glimpse into the backstory
of one character you've probably never even
wondered about: Sven the reindeer.
We know from Frozen that Sven has been with
Kristoff since he was a little boy, but we
never really learned where he was before that.
Well, wonder no longer, as it looks like we
may finally get an answer to where Sven got
his start.
In the Frozen 2 trailer, we see a young Northuldra
girl crossing a bridge cradling a baby reindeer.
This looks a lot like the girl we saw earlier
in the trailer twirling in the air in the
enchanted forest, who may very well be Elsa
and Anna's mother, Iduna.
It's very possible that either Sven or one
of his parents was born in the enchanted forest,
and came to Arendelle with Iduna and her people,
meaning that in Frozen 2, he'll be returning
to his natural home.
This seems to be supported by shots in both
this and previous trailers of Sven running
happily with a herd of reindeer, possibly
his original family.
While we have no doubt that he and Kristoff
will always remain brothers at heart, it could
be nice to see Sven finally find his place
among other reindeer.
They are, after all, better than people.
There are several shots in the new trailer
of characters rushing into battle, both Arendelle
soldiers and Northuldra warriors.
At the beginning of the trailer, they seem
to be fighting each other, although it's hard
to be sure, while at the end, they're charging
toward some unseen foe.
If they're fighting one another, it could
be the conflict Pabbie showed Elsa in her
vision, with the sword and the staff clashing
together.
Alternately, the vision could be attempting
to mislead us, and might actually symbolize
the two groups coming together and fighting
as one.
Either way, there's a strong chance that the
battle we keep glimpsing in the trailer isn't
actually one that takes place in the present
timeline.
It's very possible that this fight is one
that took place long ago, and that's what
led to the barring of the enchanted forest.
However, even if the conflict is an old one,
if it was between Arendelle, the Northuldra,
and the mysterious forces of the forest, all
of the elements are there for it to spin up
again in Frozen 2.
Perhaps this is why the Arendelle-born, magical
Elsa is so important, especially if it turns
out that her mother is Northuldra: she contains
elements of all three, and may be the one
who is finally able to bring about a lasting
peace.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.